why don't we go next to Chris from
Philly Chris welcome to the program what
is on your mind today
Chris from Philly please accept my
invitation sir
and Chris you're currently self-muted
hello yeah now you're on
okay uh I already have something
planning action but to piggyback off the
one thing the one guy said I would like
to see from Biden for the black
community
it's the whole bank's feet to the fire
for the
back hurting
of red lining that they're doing
um
absolutely I agree with that
oh I got customers coming in so I gotta
hurry up the other thing I wanted to say
was
Marty Taylor green on the uh homes Home
Security
yeah I mean what's the name
the homeland security problematic yeah
it's really problematic for the simple
fact that she was sitting there chasing
down Parkland shooter uh survivors yeah
oh I got customers coming in Chris what
kind of work do you do what kind of
customers are these
uh I'm a manager at the bear distributor
there's two of my employees called out
today so I'm working by myself at where
where are you
a beer distributor oh a beer I thought
you said at berenstained bears and I was
like what are you talking about Chris a
beer distributor all right very good
well Chris listen I'll let you get to
the customers okay
hit you back later have a good one all
right yep text me later all right okay
uh man a lot of crazy crazy stuff going
on today